THIS M FINLAND FORMALLY
DES OF N
T R PUTIN ON
D WAA  OF RUSSIA'S IAS
UK
NATOAN ALONGUSSIA'S
E EXACT
OPPOSITE OF WHAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
SAID HE WATRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
WITH THE WAR AND HLDIDENT THISTH
FOR JOING STINUKRAD YOTO U DID N
FOR,ATIC, SUDDEN CHANGES ND'S
'RE NATOARE, JUSTHNTHS
IS THIS BECAUSE YOU'RE WORRIED O
RUSSIA COULD ATTAC WELL?
THINGS TOOK , BU
FIRST,D Y ANY EMENT  NATO.
URN HERE.GH, WE ARENE
BU THEY SAIDT, TTHAT WE DO NOTE
HE FIRSTGE, 24th
OFEBY WHMA
HUGE ATTACK TO U.
G UN'S CHANGUITEWED THAT THEY AO
>> SO, YOU WERE WORRTH
LY, BUULD
SAY TH CHANGIN
ALSO, ANE SEW,
EUROPE, THE S MORE
DIVIDED.
NONALIGNED IN BETWEE
TH ALSWHAT W
KIDOOTVENED, NONNL NOW A FEW YEO
PUTIN SAID WHEOOKS AT YOUR
COUNTRY, HES FRIENDS, BUT
JO NATO, HE
I KNOW YOU SPOKE WIT
RUSSIAN ESER
W CONSIDERINN
AND BEFORE YOU CAN FULLYCO
TO BE  AHEN CA,
I WANT JUST TO THAT N ANGED.
GOING TO APPL
SH.HEE WAY HE CONFIRMED HTHINKS.
WE ARE TTE YOUTH TCUSSION WA
VERY, WHAT I WOULD
COOL.
AND HE DIDN'T REPEHO HAD HIS
PEOPLE HADINT
IS, IF FINLAND JOINS, THAT MEANS
>>THAT HE TOOK IT SO CALMLY.T?-
>> THAT HIS TONECTUALLY WILL
MATCH HO FEELS? THAT I WAABOU C
SEEMS THAT HAT REALLY IS EN
S NOMMEDIATE PROBLEMS
D THE UNANIMOUS L 30 O ALLIANCE.
T
N SAIDE DOES
NOT LOOKOSITIVELY
>> FIRSTY EVER SASREION, DO U K?
E I HAD A TELEPHONSION WH
ANTH HE SAID THAT ILL
ESTIMATE PP MEMBERSHIP, AND NOW
LOT OF DISN L.T THAT WOREDUT
TH
WILL JOIN THOTUNTRIE A
APPLICATION?
E KIND
D PART WITAND,OOE THEYDICOUNTRI.
D DEALING WITPKK
>> SPOKE WH PREN
ZENSNE JUSFEW .ASOUW,E'S EXTREM
FRUSTRATED T HWE
F INTOEMBERSHIP AS WELL?
THDENT ZELENSKYYUST WANT TLL
WAVE POSITIVURERSHIP.
MAYBE HE SEE
NOW IBLE TENE AND MAYBWAITING
IS NOT AOL
O,
ST.PE TO SPN THE THREE MONTHNC